foreign
bankruptcy
he's always been terrible with money I
bet his Jan sending them straight to the
poor house yeah women be shopping
can't believe he has a second job he's
not even good at his first one hey guys
what you talking about
okay I know what's going on talking
about Jim and Pam
if they're having sex what it looks like
I think hey hey
Michael
are you loving money problems monkey
problems no I'm not having monkey
problems why would I have monkey
problems I know you heard me correctly
oh I hate monkeys what's going on why do
you have a second job
I don't have a second job
maybe I am having an affair
with Suzanne Summers doesn't Jan have
money I don't talk to my girlfriend
about money it is rude and unsexual true
it's best to hide our money problems
from women I totally agree with you but
I don't have money problems that
all right you know what
watch this
if I had money problems
would I do this
well yeah
yeah but I destroyed it it's not even
usable anymore
what do you want to do for dinner
how about Chinese
she's really trying to save some money
that's something cheap
that was my Jeep suggestion Chinese was
my chamber suggestion I do fast food
time
and then I just need you to sign here at
this era what kind of mortgage did you
get
uh tenure
well 10 over 30 so 30 or total what what
you said 10 10 year fixed
over 30 30-year total oh 30 years okay
okay wow you'll be paying this off in
your mid 70s all right
forget about retiring when you're 65.
hey I got an idea you know that extra
bedroom if the whole girlfriend thing
never happens that's where the nurse can
live okay
yeah this is it whenever you're ready
um
oh oh okay is that supposed to come off
hey look cool carpenter ants
um I'm gonna take a little uh breather
for a second excuse me it'll be here
waiting for you oh man
a 30-year mortgage at Michael's age
essentially means that he's buying a
coffin
if I were buying my coffin
I would get one with thicker walls so
you couldn't hear the other dead people
oh
whenever you're ready Michael oh
ceilings are lower than they were last
week that I don't I don't know if you
showed me this same unit or not well
this is the unit where are all the hot
people I was told that there would be
all these attractive singles and as far
as I can tell I'm the best looking
person here there's a basic principle in
real estate that you should never be the
best looking person in the development
it's sort of common sense because if you
are
then
you had no place to go but down
is this a financial thing if it's a
financial thing what some people do is
they rent out the third bedroom
I'm going to rent the third bedroom I
want a price reduction or I am a walk
you will lose seven thousand dollars if
you
I made a right concession
Hey cuz
heard you're having money problems no
you didn't listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy all your problems go
away Creed Braden has never declared
bankruptcy when Creed Bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Schneider
how would that help Creed in Monopoly
you go bankrupt you lose you don't go by
Monopoly man that game is nuts nobody
just picks up get out of jail free cards
those things cost thousands
that is a good point bankruptcy Michael
is Nature's do-over it's a fresh start
it's a clean slate or the witness
protection program not at all
I've always wanted to be in the witness
protection program
Fresh Start no debts no baggage
already got my name picked out
Lord Rupert Everton
I'm a uh a shipping Merchant who raises
fancy dogs
that's the life
hey did you guys
are for wedding gifts
but mostly because people expect us
we're also accepting other gifts not on
the registry
however much it's awkward asking people
for money but we could really use it
why doesn't Crate and Barrel let you
register for a toaster full of cash
but you guys are looking for a kid
wedding yeah I mean if
the same for you question for you would
you guys rather have a hundred dollars
now or five thousand dollars a year from
now a hundred dollars now for sure
because you just give me fifty dollars
to cover the broker fee I put in 100 of
my own money as the gift yeah no no I'll
um the hundred I'll just take the
hundred
instead of five thousand dollars a year
from now
how sure is this the guy has an
algorithm to determine the winner of Any
Given college basketball game
don't tell Jim
I declare
bankruptcy
hey I just wanted you to know that you
can't just say the word bankruptcy and
expect anything to happen I didn't say
it I declared it still that's
it's not anything
I just love sales
I love it to death it's as simple as
that
and I don't get to do enough of it as a
manager so I took this second job
kind of as a hobby
some people have golf for
relaxing
this is a lot of credit card debt yeah
tell me about it you know Jan has my
credit cards and she's
using them as if I'm made of money she
thinks I'm a human ATM machine
okay 125 Amazon
oh Best of The Muppet Show on DVD
classic
twelve hundred dollars what's a core
Blaster extreme that is by far the best
way to strengthen your core this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist and twist it
strengthens your entire core your back
core your arm core
your
the Marine Corps actually uses it I
think that's how they got core okay the
green bar is what you spend every month
on stuff you need like a car and a house
that's so cool I have my name at the top
it's a red bar is what you spend on
non-essentials like magazines
entertainment right things like that
this scary black bar
is what you spend on things that no one
ever ever needs like multiple magic sets
professional bass fishing equipment I
can't do this so fast is this PowerPoint
[Music]
man
Angela really had a hold on him
Angela Michael I'm going to set you and
Jan up with a debt consolidator you meet
with this guy we are going to leave Jan
out of this
she has to know we will find another way
we'll ask PowerPoint Michael this is a
presentation tool your presentation tool
if you think I'm going to tell Jan about
this I'm done no you're not okay just
you're not a tool look we'll tell her
that it's bad but it could have been a
lot worse but due to some fancy
Financial footwork I was able to cut it
in half
and it's smart